يتردد صداها في شوارع
المدينة القديمة خلال خطبة الجمعة هذه.
كلماتنا عن المعنى الحقيقي للحرية
في الإسلام ، لكنها كانت أيضًا في يوم جمعة في
يوليو 2014 عندما قال محمود أن
هاتفه الخلوي فقد فجأة
استقبال جهاد المرعشوفا خلفه.
المظلة الإعلامية
الصوتية ثم ظهر أبو بكر البغدادي
وأعلن الخلافة بنفسه
قائدها وأمر جميع المسلمين
بطاعته وهذا هو بالضبط المكان الذي ألقى فيه والدي بخطابه.
من
مواقع البرادعي التي تم
تأكيدها بالكامل منذ ذلك الحين على الرغم من
مطاردتها من قبل أفضل وكالات المخابرات ،
لم يكن هناك سوى
مشاهدات قصيرة لمعلومات استخبارية متقطعة
ومعلومات متضاربة صدام وجيما ،
وهو سجين سوري متوسط المستوى من داعش مح
وم عليه بالإعدام في العاصمة العراقية ، يقول إنه لم
سبق له مثيل.  رأى جثة لكنه كان قريبًا من أولئك
الذين فعلوا ذلك منذ حوالي عام ونصف ،
ويخبرنا أن هناك محاولات من قبل
قتال خارجي  للإطاحة بالآجي ،
لكنه جعلهم جميعًا يقتلون المعارضة مع
صفوف قيادة داعش ، مما زاد من
تقليص الحاشية المحيطة بالبلدي
، بلدة سوجا المترامية الأطراف هي إحدى
المناطق التي يقول مصدر استخباراتي إن
بالا أبي انتقل إليها في عام 2015 وعقد
اجتماعات مع
لقد تحدثنا مع كبار القادة والمنازل الآمنة إلى السكان
هنا ، ولن يظهر أي منهم أمام الكاميرا ،
لكنهم قالوا لنا إنهم رأوا
القائد العسكري لداعش يدخل
ويخرج من هذا المنزل ،
وتقول مصادر عديدة أن هذا هو المكان الذي
قُتل فيه.  في عام 2015 ،
أخبرنا مصدر استخباراتي عراقي أن هذا المنزل هو
أحد الأماكن التي سيلتقي فيها مع
أبو بكر البغدادي ، وكانت هناك أيضًا
تقارير تفيد بأنه لا يمكننا تأكيد
إصابة والد بالا في نفس الغارة الجوية
، حيث قال مسؤول كبير في المخابرات العراقية
إنه  في ثلاث مناسبات على الأقل -
في العراق وواحدة في سوريا ، دعوا إلى
شن ضربات كادت أن تخرجه
من أجل التحريض - كيف يمكن لزعيم داعش
أن يقتل  لقد وصلنا من شيف
إلى حافة الجثتين ،
المخبأ السابق سفوح جبال هنري
إلى الغرب من هنا ،
تمتد مساحة شاسعة من الصحراء التي تؤدي إلى
سوريا ، تظهر الصور الحصرية التي حصلت عليها سي إن إن
ما قيل لنا لمراقب داعش.
مخابئ تتنكر في زي خيام البدو ،
صور للأنفاق داخل
الجبال كيف أن مدخلها يخفي
الحياة داخل الكهوف وفيديو موجز
حيث يناقش أحد المقاتلين
إصابته وكلهم نكات متصدعة هذا هو المكان الذي تقوم فيه
داعش بتدريب قوتها الضاربة ولا
تزال تنفذ بشكل متقطع  الهجمات
إذا نظرت إلى المناظر الطبيعية ، فهناك في
الواقع توضيح جيد جدًا لكيفية
إجبار داعش الآن على التحرك حولها ،
فهم يستفيدون من هذه الخوانق
الموجودة في جميع أنحاء هذه المنطقة بأكملها وفي
الواقع في مرحلة ما كانوا
قادرين على ذلك أثناء التنقل عبر هذه
تصعد الخوانق وتحاول زرع
بطاقة هوية هنا على الطريق هنا ،
ولا تزال داعش تحكم الليل في
مجموعات صغيرة لتقتل  دير زرع القنابل
وسرقة العراقيين يعتقدون أنهم
يقتربون من أجسادهم لكنه استعصى
عليهم أكثر من مرة واختفوا
في ظلال هذه الأراضي الخارجة عن القانون.